next question today's from Cameron
Cameron says hey David I know you're in
favor of cannabis legalization but what
other drugs would you legalize so this
is a great question let's first
understand some basics what what have we
learned about drugs and the war on drugs
over the last thirty or so years and
even going back to Prohibition in the
early 20th century we've learned number
one if you ban something it doesn't go
away that's it's so so silly because
it's so simple but a lot of people seem
still not to get that when they think
about what drug policy should be and in
fact banning something can make the cost
and price go up both the cost to create
it as well as the price to the end user
it can create black markets which are
often rife with violence and other types
of criminality all of those bad side
effects happen when you try to ban
things that people want to have access
to okay my position today is that use
and possession of all drugs should be
decriminalized absolutely 100% now where
I'm still unsure and I think that it's
really you know I could come up with
some much more black-and-white position
just for the sake of doing it for the
show but I'm simply not there yet one
way or the other on legalization of all
drugs particularly those with a very
high overdose risk and highly addictive
nature like for example heroin and
cocaine now I might come around to this
okay where I am I it's funny I barely
even feel like I need to defend the
decriminalized all drugs because it
seems at this point that there is not
even any kind of strong case against
that to be made if you understand the
realities and the facts on the ground
with the legalization of heroin the
reason that I'm sort of split is that I
recognize that there is a massive
difference between cannabis and heroin
in terms of its addictive nature in
terms of its effects on the human body
and in so many other ways the question
is are we by virtue of keeping something
like heroin
for example decriminalized instead of
legalized are we
still going to have a lot of the
problems of prohibition
if you decriminalize heroin but still
make it illegal to produce and sell and
what is out there on the streets is
unregulated and tied in with violence
and possibly mixed in with other we more
harmful chemicals are we really solving
much other than just the incarceration
piece by merely decriminalizing heroin
and cocaine and not legalizing them but
on the other side and this could be my
sort of intuitive brain rather than the
the rational brain reacting this way
am i okay saying that cocaine can be
advertised the way cannabis can be
advertised in states where cannabis has
been legalized that's less clear to me
so that's where I am right now
100% decriminalization of all drugs
legalization of all drugs I've not yet
been convinced but I'm open to it
and if you have good arguments for me by
all means send them my way because this
is something I'm still figuring out for
myself